Hank today is a very special day because
Willy bubbles and heard fighting puppy
is getting his cast off there he is back
from school he's looking at himself
right now he's like I am a handsome lad
so Sarah how do you feel about Willy
getting his cast off I am pretty excited
it's a really big day for Willy I mean
he's been building up to this for almost
his entire life look Hank he's still
walking with a limp because he thinks
that he has the cast Willy come here so
Hank those were the first two things the
nerdfighters wanted me to do for them
one see more Willy to see more of the
Yeti thing three learn a few phrases of
the Tobii in language hank even though
there are only about 150 people alive
who speak the language of toby and
there's actually a website that's like a
repository of all things toby n' but
just like any foreign language class the
sentences they teach you are absolutely
ridiculous
hank i'm about to speak toby into you
and i am not making it up
jeremy chinhan Cherokee tri he is
sucking the bark of the tree Hospital
kangi take the pumpkin hot Abajo Pongo
Tarara don't suck on that bone Hank I
want to go to the island of Toby only
knowing those three phrases and see how
far I get do not suck on the bone take
the pumpkin hey I notice you're sucking
the bark off that tree thing for walk
somewhere you would usually Drive
perfect I would usually Drive to thing
10 but I'll walk instead and do the rest
of the video on the way thing five spend
more time at the ning tank i completely
agree with the nerdfighters who said we
need to spend more time on the ning
that's why i went in and updated all of
the favorite photos including this one
and this one and this amazing
nerdfighter t-shirt and i started a
tradition of text-based question
tuesdays and you went in and put a poll
so that people can vote on their
favorite going postal blurbs
speaking of which things six bring back
the nerdfighter blurbing book club hank
i'm pleased to announce that the new
book in our book club is none other than
Catcher in the Rye by JD Salinger right
now all over the world teenage
nerdfighters are like oh god I hate that
book but I don't care I think we should
read it anyway and then you can tell me
why you don't like it and then I'll tell
you why you actually should like it
it'll be like English class only I will
have the teaching power
I am the English teacher I am mad with
power people in the neighborhood
gonna be funny when I scream into the
camera while walking things seven talk
about wind fleets book giveaway Hank as
you know there is one great piece of
nerdfighter literature in our canon and
that is mummy how do i know if i'm a
nerdfighter written by debby kiddo
the queen of australia nerdfighting
there are only like five copies of this
book in the entire world you have one I
have one our parents have one peter has
one Debbie has one I think secret
brother Tom has one but now Debbie is
auctioning off the last remaining copies
of mummy how do I know if I'm a
nerdfighter to benefit an orphanage in
Lebanon if you want the book or if you
just want to help the crease up check
out the video on YouTube that this one
is a response to thing 8 Hank the
nerdfighters want me to be like you and
give an Xbox worth of money to a charity
I did that before I left actually to
save the children you're welcome the
children thing 9 do a question Tuesday
next Tuesday ok nerdfighters leave me
your questions and comments
and finally Hank thing 10 go into a
bookstore and secretly sign one of your
books
I'm really glad someone requested this
because it's actually one of my favorite
secret hobbies but I'm a little worried
they won't have any of my books
uh-oh I was here like a week ago and
they had one of my books hmm whatever
shall I sign
Willie says remember to leave your
questions in the comments